und er antwortete ich dazu hallo mein
name ist luca warum sage ich das immer
zu beginnen
ich glaube hier ist wie ich heiße sie
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video ihr seht schritte
eingeleitet ich präsentiere euch meine
peinlichsten fakten wird sich für mich
ich will dabei nicht so lang lagern also
haben wir direkt an mit fragt nummer 1
[Musik]
ich habe meinen burrito laden in köln
zwei vitus bestellt mit verschiedenen
toppings drauf also falls du nicht
willst dass burritos sind das ist quasi
sowie ein rap aber warm und mit reis und
schicken und so drin und man kann sich
die halt selber zusammenstellen
man kann sagen okay ich will der erste
raub oder ich will sour cream oder eine
scharfe sauce oder was weiß ich und ich
hatte halt einfach riesigen hunger und
hab dann gedacht okay wenn ich da
hingehe und zweimal genau den gleichen
burrito bestelle dann komme ich locker
bei den mitarbeitern so super wie sonne
richtig verfressen das opfer deswegen
habe ich den einfach zweimal bestellt
aber ein mit ein bisschen variierenden
toppings also den ein beispielsweise mit
schicken und sauber kriegen den anderen
land halten wird schicken und keine
sorgen sondern eine schärfere soße ich
habe sogar zwischenzeitlich so getan als
hätte ich auf mein handy gekoppelt hätte
nachgeschaut was ein kumpel von mir
geschrieben hat weil er ein wollte und
eigentlich raus gegangen musste erstmal
richtig flachen letztendlich habe ich
nur anderthalb ritus gegessen weil
irgendwie habe ich zwei dann doch nicht
geschafft
[Musik]
ich wollte mal mit ein paar freunden
feiern gehen und wir sind dann in den
klub nicht rein gekommen weil ein
kollege von mir einfach zu betrunken war
und dann bin ich mit dem handy zum
türsteher gegangen und habe so heimlich
unsere unterhaltung so ein bisschen
gefilmt und hab mir das am nächsten
morgen halt angeguckt hat mir nur so
gedacht luca ich hätte auch nicht im
club gelassen aber hey
deshalb wird die peinlichste aktion
meines lebens sagt mir von meinem
youtube netzwerken der drohne
zugeschickt bekommen die man quasi mit
seinem handy verbinden kann und dann
kann man damit rum fliege und aufnahmen
macht und als ich diese drohne
ausgepackt habe habe ich die natürlich
sofort getestet und bin erst mal direkt
mit der drohne in meiner wohnung gegen
eine pflanze geflogen und die pflanze
waren kaputt und die drohne war dann
auch halb kaputt
man sollte mir sowas echt nicht geben
max eckhard gräff dass ihr ein relativ
guter kumpel von mir und ich hab mal und
ich glaube das war sogar vor der youtube
zeit von max habe ich hoffe in max
telefoniert und hab mir nebenbei
irgendwie chicken in der pfanne warm
gemacht und ich habe dann halt um die
fahne rum sage ich mal so zeitungspapier
ausgelegt damit das fett halt nicht auf
die herdplatte spiel leider ist da auch
ein wenig zeitungspapier zwischen fahrer
und heiße herdplatte gerutscht und dann
ist die zeitung an zu brennen
das wäre so cool wenn dieses gespräch
einspare aufgezeichnet worden wir
nochmal meine reaktion war nur sich die
lagerhaltung mit max und er antwortete
ich da so bestünde alle die von euch
schon führerschein haben beziehungsweise
schon mal auto gefahren sind wissen das
ja das ist einerseits immer so eine
komplette ampel gibt für den kompletten
verkehr und dann gibt es meistens doch
wenn man rechts abbiegen will hat seine
rechtsabbieger ampel und selbst wenn so
die mine ampel sag ich mal rot ist kann
es sein dass die rechtsabbieger ampel
grün ist und man dann halt da trotzdem
abbiegen kann auch wenn die haupt ampel
rot ist bei mir war es mal so dass die
haupt ampel rot war und ich stand halt
auf dieser rechtsabbiegerspur und hab
mir überhaupt nicht auf diese
rechtsseitige handel konzentriert und
die war die ganze zeit grün ich hab das
halt nicht gerafft und hinter mir war
auch keiner und mit anhalt die ganze
zeit stehen geblieben habe sie auf die
hauptrampe gekauft hab dann gewartet und
dann habe ich wieder auf die
rechtzeitige gabe punkt und dann war ich
halt wieder rot habe ich will keine
minute meines lebens verloren
[Musik]
ich schalte immer jeden morgen einfach
so um fit zu werden und ich kann auch
anders sehen die nicht abwertend also
ich finde so eine kalte dusche am morgen
ist so nicht war kaffee macht mich so
war als ich jedenfalls noch zum
gymnasium gegangen bin so von 23 jahren
habe ich dann halt auch mal eines
morgens auch alfi boost und hab dann
halt das shampoo draußen sage ich mal
vergessen vor der dusche und wollte das
dann mal wieder reinholen bin ich also
aus der dusche raus gegangen habe ich
ein bisschen abgetrocknet kenntnisse von
spiegel und wollte eigentlich oder
shampoo holen aber hab das dann in der
kurzen zeit komplett vergessen mich dann
abgetrocknet fertig gemacht und
irgendwann ist mir dann halt aufgefallen
irgendwie habe ich glaub ich vergessen
meine haare heute morgen zu waschen und
sah in dem immer wenn ich dusche mache
ich mir quasi sonne checkliste ob ich
mich rasiert habe ob ich mir die haare
gewaschen habe und erst dann mache ich
wirklich das wasser aus also irgendwie
braucht sich mal so eine situation dass
ich das vergesse ich habe mir vor gut
einem halben jahr mal ein weißes longhi
bei amazon bestellt also lohnt es sich
ja diese t-shirts die einfach war sie
ganz normal sind oder anhalten so ein
bisschen länger also die irgendwie vorne
normale dann hinten so ein bisschen
länger einfach was man halt cool und
einem rudi oder sonstigen kann
jedenfalls hat mir dieses long sie dann
so gut gefallen dass ich mir das gleiche
long kino fünfmal in weiß bestellt habe
noch dreimal ins schwarze und noch
dreimal insomnie wie blau und seitdem
habe ich nie wieder probleme damit
irgendwie ein weißes t-shirt in meinem
schrank zu finden oder irgendein anderes
titel was man uns eine moody anziehen
kann ich hab das halt mit voll vielen
produkten irgendwie so dass wenn ich
weiß okay ich habe das oft an oder ich
benutze das oft dann kaufe ich mir davon
halt direkt enorm viel beispiel habe ich
in meiner studentenbude
in köln derzeit auch irgendwie ab
packungen spaghetti und acht packungen
bolognese soße weil ich einfach weiß
dass ich mit mindestens einmal die woche
sollen 500 gramm päckchen verbraucher
genauso oft mit shampoo und deo ich habe
irgendwie in einer wohnung drei vier
dosen shampoo und drei vier losen deo
weil ich einfach weiß okay das sind
produkte die man immer braucht nennt
mich ruhig einfach ein guter kumpel von
mir also setzte es cocktails die auf
youtube er hat mich mal in köln besucht
und normalerweise ist so der klingelt
und nicht gefragt hannover ist das erste
mal auf mich zurück auf einen knopf und
bat das mal bildet quasi rein aber er
hat halt gesagt erwartet halt unten raus
noch nicht weil wir ihn noch los wollten
was essen und bei mir im wohnungs
gebäudes ist halt so man geht so eine
treppe runter dann geht man quasi an
seiner wand vorbei geht man rechts und
dann ist daher diese glastür wo quasi
leute vorstehen und ich habe mir halt
gedacht ok wer bestimmt irgendwie witzig
wäre ich jetzt das netz an mache und
dann den blitz so um die ecke lupe und
dann steht der es gemacht hat irgendwie
klimas oder irgendwie so war ich habe
das dann gemacht und dann ist aber genau
in dem moment meine untermieterin
gekommen und danach nicht ihr quasi voll
mit meinem handy in die schnauze gefilmt
das war so ca die peinlichste aktion von
mir in den letzten zwei drei wochen also
dass ich wirklich einfach dampf so
stellt euch vor ihm filmt irgendwie
wasser kommt um die ecke sondern seht
auch einfacher untermieterin oder
irgendeine andere person was sie aber
nicht gedacht hätte
[Musik]
wie ihr vielleicht wisst weit vom 22 bis
zum 30
dezember im skiurlaub in österreich und
dort hatten wir halt ein fitnessstudio
im hotel drinnen inkludiert und das war
eigentlich jeden tag leer und dann war
ich die ersten zwei drei tage da halt
immer so drittes normal trainiert und am
vierten tag habe ich dann wieder rein
dann wieder alles leer und hättest du
gedacht ja jetzt mache ich einfach meine
eigene mutter jahren ab da die kopfhörer
aus meinem handy raus gezogen habe das
handy da hingelegt lauter angemacht
irgendwie deutsch web unter anderem halb
gehört und habe halt eine halbe stunde
trainiert habe ich halt mein handy
genommen musik ausgemacht wollte also
raus gehen und sie auf einmal sowohl das
sind zwei leute auf dem stepper hinter
der wand gewesen ich hab dann relativ
schnell geschaltet und hab dann halt
gesagt so hallo entschuldigung wie lange
sind sie das studieren diese herr schon
seit anderthalb stunden laufen wir sind
nicht so hoch
entschuldigung dass ich meine musik die
er zehn metern mussten ich habe in dem
moment auch wieder als ich aus dem haus
gehöre ich musste so lachen hat mir nur
so gedacht luca was bist du für ein
mensch
[Musik]
der zehnte und letzte peinliche fakt ich
heute mit mich vorstelle hat etwas mit
meinem neuen handy zu tun
also ich erzählt soll ich mal ihr wisst
denke ich alle dass ich ein apple fan
bin also ich habe eine nahezu jedes
produkt mit einem ipad nämlich videos
auf die ich irgendwie als app oder wenn
ich einen game spiele oder irgendwie so
ein macbook habe ich immer unterwegs mit
mit dem ich einfach arbeite mit der
serie in sachen drauf da keine ahnung
also mit macbooks am meisten ich habe
mein weg auf dem ich quasi allgemeinen
stationär arbeit ich habe eine and the
water ist meine uhr ist und das soll
überhaupt nicht angeberisch sein oder so
sondern einfach weil ich damit am
meisten klar komme also alle geräte
miteinander verbunden ich habe überall
meine termine wenn ich mir im iphone
foto machen wie es direkt auf macbook
auf dem heimweg auf ist ja auch egal ich
will gar keine samsung app wilhelms
scheiße jetzt auslösen jeder soll der
nutzen läufer bock hat aber das ist auf
jeden fall der grund wieso ich mir bei
dem launch vom iphone sieben direkt das
iphone 711 bestellt habe bisher das
iphone sieben plus das es ja noch gar
nicht draußen dann habe ich aber die
bestellung von dem iphone 7 + nach ein
paar tagen storniert weil ich dann halt
reviews gesehen habe und so videos nur
dass leute irgendwie schon in der hand
hat nur gesagt haben du bist echt großer
fan die jedenfalls habe ich das ganze
dann abgebrochen und habe mir dann quasi
zu weihnachten jetzt das normale iphone
7 gekauft in mattschwarz und hab das
dann ausgepackt haben allerdings gedacht
ich hätte schon gern das plus die kamera
ist besser der akku ist besser ich glaub
ich schick das wieder zurück und dann
habe ich quasi wieder mein iphone 7
zurückgeschickt und haben wir dann
dieses handy hier gekauft also genau das
was ich mir zu beginn eigentlich schon
bestellt habe nämlich das iphone 7 plus
in mattschwarz weil das heidi wie
kratzer oder neuere kamera hat weil das
messung akku hat und zwar dort sofort
und außerdem habe ich ja noch ein iphone
7 bestellt was ich euch verlost habe
wenn ihr meinen kanal abonniert ich weiß
jetzt nicht wirklich bekannt gegeben
aber unter den videos mehr als 1,1
millionen kommentare also das dauert
noch ein bisschen das heißt ich hatte
jetzt insgesamt schon vier iphone 7
also jetzt gerade wir zwar nur das eine
hier in gebrauch aber irgendwie schon
peinlich das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich hoffe ihr konntet irgendwas
peinlich ist mit allen fakten dazu
gewinnen oder so also lasten leiter wenn
euch das gefallen hat solltet ihr
vielleicht awards am iphone video von
meinem neuen handy an ich habe das
gleiche schon mal vor ein zwei jahren
hochgeladen
aber es ist halt schon jetzt habe ich
noch drauf und so als wenn ihr das wollt
schreibt mal
iphone 7 in die kommentare und dann sehe
ich ja wie viele das wollen hier findet
hier 12 die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
segment ihm einen kanal abonnieren es
ist free kostenlos und ihr werdet
benachrichtigt wenn ich neue videos
hochladen und es ist cool und fanny und
was weiß ich und hier findet gegen
anderes video eingeblendet was bestimmt
auch mega cool ist und das gewinnspiel
vom iphone 70 sich die klage auf